i heard they have decent mexican food in
chicago because there is a big there is
a big mess
i'm from a mexican like area they don't
get the best relax you're you're in
california you're in canada
tacos wacky where did you go
i went to pink taco i went to
[ __ ] that's your [ __ ] problem
look look look pink taco is white people
tacos all right listen let me tell you i
went to
nah that was mexican food i mean listen
to you i went to a couple spots where
they hit tacos was it a truck was it a
truck i did the truck before too but
that it wasn't only the truck though you
have to go to leo's taco truck
leo's taco truck i don't like eating at
the trucks i feel like i'll be getting
sick or maybe it's just my thing it's a
mind thing
i just feel like i was getting sick you
can't bring up pink taco though
that [ __ ] was so weak
god awful but pink taco is [ __ ] white
it's a white person owned establishment
i'm assuming this is this when i first
got down the first time me ever coming
to la when i got signed to one in 2019
i'm trying to find hella [ __ ] to eat i
can't find it now since since then i've
been out here 100 times and i still no
no no no no no i gotta get you right no
whole pizza got the good wings
that's it
like i don't really y'all the
drive-throughs like all other you gotta
tap in man yeah i gotta tell you are you
in the valley you're like over this way
yeah there's great come on literally
just drive around north hollywood or
chef grizzly spoke with that no i don't
know that is some black people [ __ ] chef
grizzlies fire
steak
i'm not mad at that i like macaroni and
snakes not black people's treats so a
lot of people i love soul food you ever
have concreter not like that when i say
black people no i have probably